let's cover jury through 2014 you're
watching samsung stage right here at
Gamescom for its slash III and i'm very
happy to be joined by Pete Smith from
Sony Computer Entertainment and Tom
O'Conner also from Sony Computer
Entertainment Europe s EE dudes maybe
you guys can clear this up for me well
everyone thought because Media Molecule
had said we're not going to be d3 that
there's gonna be no LittleBigPlanet game
and then suddenly lights up on the show
floor and is a little big fan of game
but what's going on what you know what
before I answer that it's so cool where
do you get an actual genuine
announcement that nobody knows about we
totally yeah awesome
I just a morning we were like it's still
not got out it's still not out and then
you know and then when the logo went on
screen yeah and everyone went wow a
genuine surprise Ali was a little big
planet as well
I was just such a doll it was great it
was and the way it was presented with
the lights has popped on and then I'm
guessing was a bunch of devs from sumo
we're just standing on stage then yeah
well it was also Lee I wasn't really
with us Oh excellent
and yeah okay let's talk about
LittleBigPlanet 3 you guys it started
off and it is okay this looks like the
living planet we know and love what new
is going to be brought to the table and
then suddenly all these freakish
shocking things and fat men and flying
beasts come here explain for the folks
at home who missed it and what's the
what what's the sort of the USP of
LittleBigPlanet 3 well I've been the
first obvious thing that you'll notice
is the characters and I think you know
you've been able to do so many different
things in LittleBigPlanet you can create
pretty much whatever you want but you've
kind of always been quite tired to sack
bug and so we were introduced to so many
things across let me find it one a
little bit better too we thought
actually the characters literally what
we haven't really played with too much
and sex always a pretty endearing
character like he has his place in the
sort of modern video game character
Waterloo yeah and he's kind of a bit of
a PlayStation mascot yeah I'm but you
know we thought let's let's really have
some fun with these characters and it's
amazing how much they change the
gameplay and it's always great to get
something which is so visually different
but then also something which completely
changes the game and the possibilities
because it's not just those characters
but you can customize the characters
so many different ways that really opens
things up for the creators the creators
love them they absolutely love them and
yet the creator's love them yet people
just pick it up straight away can play a
feel the differences straightaway so
it's got such such a nice thing about
there's so much in the game yeah as with
every little big planet this just tons
and tons and tons of stuff is that a new
challenge having the fact that there's
four different types of characters if
one thing with LittleBigPlanet was it's
very accessible having four characters
does that make it a little bit more a
little bit more difficult to try and
like explain that what their abilities
are on one on oh not at all because the
great thing about LittleBigPlanet is is
that's very physical so for example you
saw on the screen we've got a cat called
toggle and you can change between big
and heavy and small and light and we've
seen people at the show today playing
for the first time they need no
explanation they can take it off and the
straighten implant so it's really really
accessible it's great so people are able
to play it today and they didn't know it
existed 24 her exactly yeah you guys
done good let's look at the gameplay
that we're showing here at the moment on
the streams you just explained for the
folks which which characters were
looking at and the sort of the ways in
which they change living planet yeah
sure so the kite II just saw then that's
all talk and all talks like our fish
four-legged character let's have been in
Little Big Planet and and the great
thing about all sockets is that it gives
really really fast so you can create
really fast gameplay you can create like
an endless runner and I'll talk and wall
jump it's really really cool to kind of
play with the kite that feels so
different to sup boy and of course you
can fully customize all the characters
just like you can customize Sackboy so
with the game we'll have lots of
different costumes you can collect lots
of customization options and people can
have a lot of fun with that
excellent I want a reminder folks at
home if you have any questions that
offer the guys up on stage here at
Daniel Dwyer and Twitter and I'll do my
best to get them over and it was already
a bunch coming Nick and Stephanie I
can't believe this questions are not
even asked will you guys be selling
plushies of all the new characters watch
this space I think my eyes at guys like
us I think they're my fear might be
American for some of this stuff what we
well up as well is new costumes and
downloadable costumes as well sack boys
wardrobe is just amazing yeah already
and we'll be doing that for the for the
new characters as well so level creation
has always been a really important part
a little bit plan and especially a
little big planet ooh and the way in
which people are making different wholly
different types of gameplay and
considering now
manically you don't just have one type
of character you've got four that
creates new challenges for people making
levels surely a lot about challenges it
creates new opportunities and you can
choose whatever you want so you could do
you could do an endless runner without
sock yeah
and that'd be really easy yeah just be
so easy to do that but then you can make
it much much more complicated you can
actually switch between characters
so with this actually we've introduced
four new characters not three because
big toggle is a separate character it's
a little toggle how okay so in the game
we choose that you switch between the
two of them yes yep but actually as a
creator you could switch between sackboy
and toggle sackboy and sweep so you can
join in the level you can actually
change yourself so there's loads of
opportunities to make really interesting
gameplay but it's very very immediate
you know odd socket is like it's like a
dog yeah and it's kind of just obvious
it's like yeah well I get that press X
and it jumps like a dog so I'll make a
running game so and we tried hard to
make them really immediate there's so
much fun
up top wall jumping particularly yeah
really good are you guys had a little
bit of trouble on the stage yesterday
there was some latency happening with
the yeah we have like issues we what I
love the bet that though is that when we
were watching it in the war room and it
wasn't happening the cheer when I'm
sorry [ __ ] up there was like yeah oh
yeah it was don't bigots hear the
proposal hey but that seems to me to
wonder if the back panel is a um like it
is a game that has seen a lot of
releases in a relatively short period of
time like PlayStation 3 came out when
LittleBigPlanet came out it was it was a
couple of years after launch and then
there was that bundle pack 2 was a big
game and and I believe had games on the
Vita as well but still when other Planet
3 came on stage you guys seemed to get
the whole crowd there's something
visually about it that just seems to get
with people like it just makes them
smile yeah so with these new characters
how much of it is to do with like
opening up new types of gameplay and how
much of this to do with just making
characters that people actually like
looking at at all at all was all about
the gameplay you know right from the
start we wanted to make characters which
felt completely different and obviously
look different as well but it was you
know we spent a lot of time really
thinking about
the character had to introduce a new
style of game yeah and if we didn't have
that then we wouldn't have been able to
have the carrot there so you know a
flying character is quite an obvious one
then I think you know giving introducing
a four-legged carrot there was kind of
obvious and it was that last one
we were like what should we do yeah you
know we should do something maybe
something big do something small
just big and small so and we go there
was a part in is where is it swoop the
flying character and picked up one of
the other characters how can you do that
all the time is there a way of like just
piggybacking each other through the
levels or it what it is is that we the
level that we showed at the press
conference yesterday we built that to
showcase the abilities of the characters
okay so we saw a couple of comments
online saying Oh Swoopes got too much
kind of like power
yes map so P yeah yes who Sophia the
thing with that is that in the way we
build the game is that you know there's
not just you can't just change the sweep
at any time and take over the level okay
it's like that the game place built
around the characters through the
through the main adventure well and
presumably then because you guys seem to
leave all the tools that you have at
your disposal to the creators as well
that they'll be able to make rule sets
like that as well yeah you can even take
yeah you can take a cat then you could
you can use this default abilities or
you can completely change their
abilities okay Carl Duran acid burn 19
on twitter is asking have you tightened
the controls for a little big planet
because he felt that the other games are
a little bit floaty in terms of the
platforming we are we actually have yeah
it's a big topic of this go specially we
have tightened it up a little bit and
actually it makes a big difference
yeah not massive change and but but yet
Judas just I don't I think the people it
was kind of funny a lot of people
weren't bothered by their what's been
termed floaty physics yeah but then some
people were it's kind of a bit polarized
I think those who weren't bothered won't
really notice any difference but I think
those who were it's just tightened up
just a bit I am yeah I think I think I
think people will be happy I would say
that yeah the Marmot Marmite controls
and exactly that you're probably I would
say to be about people that would be
happy to know that it's been addressed a
little a little bit anyway and I think
because we're backwards compatible with
all of the levels oh yeah so I
graphically changed
question here from my initials on
Twitter can you play on the new
characters on the old LittleBigPlanet
levels so no it's a short answer and
basically because like what tom was
saying before we need to control when
people can play the characters you just
can as well so if you create a level you
will choose what current is allowed in
your level because you could spend like
weeks and weeks making a really
technically challenging level but all of
the ground based characters and then
someone could just select swoop and fly
straight through and in the leaderboards
are a bit kind of exhausting but you can
just choose what you want when you want
so that's that's kind of the way we get
around that from it from a creators
point of it Oh M Pass games in the
series have always had pretty
interesting stories are you guys going
to have a full campaign as it were are
you gonna lean towards the creation
stuff have more heavily this time
yes we've definitely got a you know a
really great play experience from start
to finish and you know brand new story
brand new adventure with loads new ways
to play you know and our adventure is a
showcase as well as being just a great
game on its own so definitely a full
play mode there Craig's Lindsay's asking
well we have Steven frying
LittleBigPlanet 3
Oh William we confirmed that order yeah
yeah exclusive here in the games by
stage Steven Blair I'm really running
hey exactly a much a little bit fun
without Steve I just wouldn't work with
it thanks for the question there Craig
really appreciate it and yeah is there
anything else in terms of like stuff
that you haven't shown you seem to make
a really good level that showcased a lot
of what's new with other band 3 we're
anything else in here that maybe we we
haven't seen yet I think I've been from
a create point of view this all out
there's loads and we're going to be
talking a lot about a lot more of that
later it's a great thing with LBP really
is there's just so many things each each
kind of time we talk about it we can
always say about new things because
there's so much it's all about but yeah
this there's a lot more in the game
there's the characters bring a lot more
than I think we've even shown in this
but yet we've we always try and build
upon the existing sort of creates
creation tools yeah Janet we've also
tried hard to make make things a little
bit more accessible as well so there's
some really cool features in there which
are going to help people to create
a little bit easier as well which I
think it's gonna just Brom the amount of
people who come out to get they get to
grips with the great tools but this just
low there's so many sino one thing that
the community will love like we talk a
lot about the new characters we've all
done some really great features for
Sackboy as well you know you can really
kind of expand the way he uses power-ups
in the game as well so we're gonna talk
more about that and another time but the
community will go mad for that while
still its want to touch on one thing as
well that some people have been saying I
saw on Twitter yesterday obviously sumo
are working on this game not Media
Molecule
assume we're based up in Sheffield
living is all right yeah so I am just
from from a developer standpoint
sometimes people are a little bit
worried when their favorite franchises
like pushed over to somebody else and
soon we'll have a bit a history with
lieblick planet did at the cross
controller Packer I think for the planet
- and what would you say to folks who
are maybe just wondering if it would it
be a different take on LittleBigPlanet
this time around I think I think this is
there's a slightly different and taken
that it's new new team with new ideas
and so that's that's a really positive
thing well I think you can see with the
demo you know we've I've worked on a
little big planet since since they want
yeah you know we're really pushing to
make sure that it still feels very LBP
ish and i think you can see from the
demo that it does but i think the
introduction of some new ideas is is
only positive and they're a great
starting point Media Molecule has done a
fabulous job a medium molecule still
take a look at the game and you know
they'll always express their opinions
and we have all the developers involved
as well who've worked on a little big
planet for a while as well so the
LittleBigPlanet developer family is is a
big big family cool Pete and Tom for
Sony Computer Entertainment Europe thank
you so much for coming on and showing us
live a band of three folks at home as
well I can't wait and to see more about
this game so thanks very much for
spending time with GameSpot today and
we're gonna be back with battlefield
hardline in just a few minutes but first
of all gonna check out a little bit of
fable legends